hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to V is calling now this is
a type of not quite simulator game but
you're a person who's going on a video
date and things aren't what they seem
what's my first name marki poo I call
accepted hello hello hey is this video
working
it sure is V yeah it is it's nice to
finally see you even if it is just a
video yeah I wish we could have gotten
dinner or something don't worry
this will definitely be more fun and how
in the world would this be more fun than
dinner if you don't mind me asking
really I somehow doubt that very much
oh really
why is that well just getting to know
you and everything will be more fondness
especially through a computer screen
again I have my doubts 2% sure about
that like a digital love story oh it's a
little early to be talking about love
we're on our barely first date over here
that makes that makes sense sure it does
I am go with that this could turn into
love after all Wow I'm desperate
yeah anyway tell me a little bit about
yourself you know four foot nine super
manly let's see well today at work you
first yeah I want to know about you your
needs why don't you tell me first I'm
very curious to know yeah well I'm more
curious oh that was me nevermind sorry
nobody has asked me to go first before a
goose and pie well I'm a computer
scientist and I know a lot about
computers ah sorry that sounds so bland
no not at all I just do art and stuff oh
really
I play the trumpet I just bought a red
trumpet and it's delightful I don't know
that much about computers themselves
that seems it's the opposite of what I
know well it doesn't seem like that what
what do you mean you seem like a pretty
smart person oh gee thanks probably not
as smart as you miss computer scientist
really really it's nothing since being a
graphic designer seems really tough in
itself sometimes wait did I ever tell
you as a graphic designer
oh of course you did did you forget
already now I have bad memory but I'm
pretty sure maybe no no I'm pretty sure
I didn't tell you no I don't think I
ever told you we did you mentioned
working with computers in art yeah but
it's obvious you're a graphic designer
okay I think it's really cool that you
are I'm just not physically capable to
do art I mean it's more of a mental
thing I think I'll just stick to
computers let's see you can do art
whoops whoa what did I do
uh-oh is this the same screen okay I
just saved all right
you seem pretty attached to computers oh
you don't even know I'm on the computer
all the time because I'm actually a
robot do you get out much not often not
at all actually
I'm usually inside doing my job because
she's a computer she's a computer
scientist don't you ever want to try new
things usually No
all right then well if you Oh what was
that
oh no oh [ __ ] Oh what was why did
something just disappear from my desktop
yeah folder definitely used to be there
oh I didn't notice something up here
maybe really check again oh I'm telling
you it's gone do you know what's
happening I have a funny feeling maybe
you might know what's happening my files
those were really important I mean your
computer scientist does this ever happen
randomly not really your computer made
myriad izing files by itself yeah that
happens it'll do that sure sometimes
I'm glad it's not urgent and it for
something like this to disturb our call
oh well there goes more don't worry
about it to be honest I am a bit worried
of what let's see about my computer
files of course my computer files they
keep disappearing they were really
important don't grin at me all smug like
oh what a shame
okay you're being very demeaning okay oh
crap what was that oh boy woah that's
what I said Oh No
what's happening in my computer oh no
holy [ __ ] your computer oh my god lady
wow that's creepy it's mine now oh uh
huh okay what what is my first name
mark oh [ __ ] [ __ ] happened oh hello V
okay hang on
I'm gonna I'm gonna go forward a bit
okay well today at work got back from
work it was pretty rough day since I had
to deal with clients at all and it
wasn't too bad I guess I worked on the
computer all day and made some art so it
was enjoyable working on the computer
you don't say I found that really really
see ironic really interesting you think
so Thanks I definitely do definitely
definitely
since being graphic design is really
tough in itself sometimes wait a minute
this is weird okay so this is what I
said before okay so I saved huh I
probably did forget it's okay I think
it's really cool your designer I could
never do art you could if you wanted to
trust me
I can't why not I'm just not physically
capable to do art cuz she's a computer
more of a mental thing not to give new
heart anybody can create art you just
have to put your heart into it my heart
yeah like what makes you happy
I don't know computers that's all I
really know well as long as you're
passionate you can always create
something oh did I say something wrong
no you're right it was just really
thoughtful I can teach you sometimes
oh that's not necessary trust me all
right then well if you Oh what was that
whoa who is what hey this is leading
down the same path uh-oh folder
definitely used to be there
all right must save again here telling
you it's gone what the hell is happening
I was really important let's see
freaking out you don't seem to care I
just met you like five minutes ago
so ah more files do worry about it to be
honest I'm a bit worried about what it
say about our date of course I care
about us oh this isn't ruining our date
well that's not something to worry about
of all the times to have computer
problems what was that what was that
it's me oh she's admitting it that's
different it's you sorry I I've been
trying to take over your computer what
I'm now realizing that that was a
mistake you don't deserve that I'm sorry
wait Oh No oh she put everything back
and gonna end it wait there was one more
up like there was one option where I was
kind of accusatory towards her could I
like could that change anything see do
you know what's happening no it's a tank
or a computer
no she just goes I think oh man is there
only two endings there might be I have
no idea okay wow that was a short that
was so cool though I was into it it was
so creepy all the sudden in the other
option like wow that would creepy fast
but I like that I wonder if there really
are only two options if there are men I
don't see how any other way for them to
go because towards the end there just
seemed like there were two different
routes but there's probably some
internal flags on like how nice you are
and being on the actual date and all
that but either way this was really cool
this was made for a game jam as well I
believe but I'm not 100% sure but it's
really good idea and I like it a lot so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of this in
the comments below I'd love to hear your
input on it and maybe maybe this
developer will make more stuff like this
in the future this might even be the
same person that made that like one
nights dancing it kind of seems similar
to that but probably not probably not at
all but either way thank you everybody
so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye
really